hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the water balloon
challenge
hey guys so we're going to be doing a
water balloon toss if you've done this
before it's basically a challenge where
you toss it anyway so we're gonna
continue on with the water balloon
challenge if you haven't seen this
before we toss balloons back and forth
and we take one step back for each time
we toss it every each person take one
step back each time and then whoever
breaks it loses and whoever loses gets
punished great cool all right cool nice
you take a step back oh yeah you're
welcome
bad throws disqualify you huh yeah
oh it's short oh now I'm sticking a worm
into your nose eating their brain okay
okay now ready wait and tyloo's turn
nice hahaha you stay okay whoever
catches it moves back yes
this is uh against procedurally less fun
huh your poop face you ready
bad throw you're out you're out this is
a bad throw I gotta look up your nose
absolute silence if anything golf claps
that's the only thing that cheer
raucously the whole time huh ooh
you just lost them yep no actually that
was so bad you know get another try no I
don't know one more try one more try one
more try
we're already farther than before it's
okay this is the longest toss ya know
for me okay yeah that's how it works
yeah that is how that works
all run forward if you need me that was
a good throw
that was a clean throw clean throw
good throw I didn't take my phone out of
my pocket yours is in water for nine
it's not waterproof
okay well that sucks for you there's
such a thing as a Redemption from the
losers breath we get further out than
the winners do okay no because this is
gonna work so this is your losers
bracket we all lost so now we're doing a
triangle timers bracket bracket so how
are we are we going to yes yeah okay
I sure do Bob buckle let's go look like
my fault when you drop it good hands
I'm gonna get stick shot hang on guys
wait hang on wait
I got it wait okay clean toss bad pitch
good cost so now it's gonna be Bob and
Ethan together and they're gonna go and
whoever the winner is
after Wade and I go then the two winners
will come back so this is how the if the
first person playing loses they have
another dish is how we planned it yeah
this is our planet yeah trimming them in
the style Bob remember we're working as
a team kind of not really
you guys are directly competitive yeah
chase you're in competition the winner
of the loser's is going to play the
winner of the winners the second which
will then determine the big winner okay
can we just start now let's go I want a
clean game on a fun game entertain these
people if you don't we'll kill you all
right we're trying to win now huh
[Music]
[Applause]
good game was a good game I think that
was a crappy balloon
I think the balloons were deflated big
soldiers find sixes are played please
don't close up on my nipple we're good
with this one search log let me another
regulation water balloon you're good
good good good clean game what's your
going
oh it was the nails really did me and
now it's a face-off it's a feasel we'll
just continue from here
I gotta get a good college
[Applause]
your beard what is in my hand no your
hand got my beard wet
so I've won the winners bracket Ethan
it's one the losers bracket so the
winner and the loser winners will come
together enough okay so well since he
tied it I will let you begin okay sounds
fair
red versus blue
who's gonna win you know who's gonna win
anything
purple nope
little bit it's okay he's wearing aunty
pop happy pop no that was totally me
it went right there cradled right out of
my palm okay
this is not fair not fair
you made the room
[Applause]
you won which is really great incredible
good job you really ought showed us you
get the prize come up against this oh
great
can't wait for you surprised I already
know what's happening come here I'm just
gonna embrace it I thought I already
know okay yeah I'm gonna offer you
something not for me something I will
take your place you delete your chair
it's really tempting it's kind of a
win-win I thought you were just gonna
say you'll take his place if he declares
you the winner gal do that now win more
than you want to get like slaughter
Ethan wanted absolutely Ethan's a
champion so cool your champion just let
it be now and I'm better than mark yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you everybody so much for watching
we had a ton of fun here thank you
everybody that participated thank you
everybody that had a lot of fun while we
were here and thank you all so much for
watching and as always I will see you
[Music]
[Applause]
the next video bye-bye
[Applause]
[Music]